les collections de prêt-à-porter les
femmes réchauffer l'été prochain par le
soleil andalou le créateur anglais
alexander mcqueen propose une collection
entre flamenco et corridas un défilé
dédié à la paix dans le monde qui se
déroulait aujourd'hui au stade français
reportage estelle cola patrick des
chenilles car il est sans doute le
créateur le plus attendu de la saison
après un départ tonitruant de la
prestigieuse maison givenchy alexander
mcqueen volant fin de ses propres ailes
pourquoi j'ai quitté givenchy parce que
je ne voulais plus jamais travailler
pour quelqu'un d'autre au mcqueen c'est
ma société je ne veux plus travailler
pour une autre marque je veux exister
par moi même et pourtant la tutelle du
groupe givenchy et vient là
juridiquement mcqueen n'appartient pas
dans sa totalité à alexander mcqueen
mais au groupe gucci qui en détient 51%
ils m'ont offert la liberté parce que
c'est un groupe qui investit dans
l'aspect créatif le fantasme
l'imaginaire transfert de créateurs
rachats fusions sur le terrain du luxe
tous les coups sont permis
d'autant que le marché pourrait bien
flirter avec les 100 milliards d'euros
670 milliards de francs d'ici à dix ans